Deberíamos hacerlo más a menudo.
¿Cuándo fue la última vez?
Pues igual hace 8 meses o así o igual el año.
Ahí estábamos todos.
Sí, estaban cortos. Ya no.
Si eres vegetariano desde los 16, Robert,
¿por qué te vas a comer esa chuleta?
¿Que comí? ¿Algo como esto?
Si tú eres más de monte que las cabras, Aritz,
¿qué haces abrazándote en la playa?
Levantemos el corazón,
demos Gracias al señor nuestro Dios.
El señor esté con vosotros.
Vivamos siempre libres de pecado
y protegidos de toda perturbación
mientras esperamos la gloriosa.
Pero si hace siglo y 2º que no pisas 1 iglesia Ane,
¿qué pintas tú en misa?
Os Dejo lazo del área,
no llega más. A Gasti sí que la ha cazado otro compañero.
Cuidado ese balón, que se pase el remate,
gol, gol.
Si eres socio el Atleti desde chaval Mikel,
¿por qué animas a la real?
¿Cosas importantes que contar?
Así que vamos a hacer 1 Gran inversión,
la que estoy preparando
para la empresa. Y tú, como eres jefe de planta,
espero y confío en que puedas solucionar los pequeños.
Pero si estás harto del curro, Víctor,
quiero que seas recto.
¿Y por qué pasas los domingos con tu jefe?
Me humillas, ¿eh?
Si somos de izquierdas de toda la vida,
¿por qué vamos a creer 1 gobierno con el PNV?
Elige izquierda,
vota el Carre, ¿quién podemos?